(sirène)
- C'est une sirène qui servait,
dans les années 60, 70,
à appeler les pompiers.
Depuis le début de la
mobilisation, c'est vraiment
l'appel aux citoyens de dire :
Bien, il y a une activité
de mobilisation, venez vous
regrouper, venez marcher
avec nous.
- Senneterre, vendredi 10 h,
la sirène retentit aux quatre
coins de la municipalité,
non pas pour prévenir
la population d'un danger,
mais pour l'inviter à
se rassembler devant l'hôpital.
En quelques minutes,
des dizaines de citoyens sont
réunis. Le moment est important;
l'avenir de l'urgence en dépend.
- Le ministre va être ici
dans quelques minutes. On lui a
demandé d'être bien sensible
à la distance qu'il a parcouru
entre Val-D'Or et Senneterre
pour qu'il comprenne vraiment
que, nous, cette distance-là,
on va l'avoir à parcourir
dans une ambulance.
- À moins d'un revirement
de situation, l'urgence
sera dorénavant fermée
16 heures par jour. Les patients
de Senneterre devront parcourir
les 70 km qui les séparent
de l'hôpital de Val-D'Or,
le temps de pallier la pénurie
d'infirmières en Abitibi.
- Travailler dans des conditions
comme ça, c'est inquiétant.
- Une décision qui met la santé
de la population en péril,
selon les médecins qui
travaillent au centre de santé
et qui étaient prêts à revoir
les horaires pour éviter
la fermeture.
Dre CATHERINE CHARBONNEAU,
Centre de santé de Senneterre
- Le monde, ils n'ont pas
un diplôme de médecin dans
la tête pour dire pour se dire :
Ah! ça, c'est pas urgent,
ça peut attendre à demain.
Ça, hum... OK, il faudrait que
je prenne l'ambulance.
Dr SIMON THÉBERGE, médecin,
Centre de santé de Senneterre
- C'est sûr que c'est difficile
comme médecin de se dire :
bien, à 16 h ou 16 h 30,
il y a peut-être quelqu'un
qui va arriver dans 30 minutes
et on ne pourra pas être là
pour les aider. Personnellement,
professionnellement,
c'est un peu malaisant.
- Leur dernier espoir :
plaider leur cause directement
auprès du ministre de la Santé,
qui est venu prendre le pouls
de la situation.
- Monsieur Dubé, bonjour!
- Je vais vous donner le coude.
- Bon!
- Ça va bien?
- Merci d'être à Senneterre.
- L'accueil est chaleureux,
mais la demande reste ferme.
- Gardons notre urgence!
Gardons notre urgence!
- À 300 kilomètres de là,
à l'autre bout de la région,
des mamans et futures mamans
se sont donné rendez-vous
devant l'hôpital de Ville-Marie
pour dénoncer la fermeture
du département d'obstétrique.
Depuis avril dernier,
impossible d'y accoucher.
Encore une fois, les patients
doivent parcourir de longues
distances pour obtenir
des soins.
- Un troisième bébé,
on sait pas non plus
comment ça peut arriver.
- À 29 semaines de grossesse,
Marie-Christine ne se fait plus
d'illusion, elle devra accoucher
à Rouyn-Noranda, à 1 heure 30
de route de chez elle.
MARIE CHRISTINE ROBERT, mère de
2 enfants, enceinte de 29 sem.
- L'idée d'accoucher dans
mon auto, ça me tente pas
et l'idée d'accoucher
dans un ambulance non plus.
- Et je savais que si je perdais
mes eaux chez moi, je ne
rendrais pas nulle part.
- Nadia Rocheleau a aussi
appris en pleine grossesse
qu'elle devrait accoucher de
son 3e enfant loin de la maison.
NADIA ROCHELEAU,
mère de 3 enfants
- Je capotais un peu,
c'était vraiment stressant.
En fait, j'ai fait environ
tous les plans qu'il y a pas.
M'organiser pour être d'avance,
aller me trouver un endroit
où aller rester à Rouyn,
espérer que ça débloque,
organiser mes enfants.
- Pour la députée solidaire
de Rouyn-Noranda-Témiscamingue,
le gouvernement doit prendre
conscience que les distances
aggravent les conséquences
de la pénurie d'infirmières
dans la région.
ÉMILISE LESSARD-THERRIEN députée
Rouyn-Noranda-Témiscamingue, QS
- Demander à des femmes
de partir de Ville-Marie
et d'aller accoucher
à Rouyn-Noranda, c'est 130 km,
je comprends pas comment
ils peuvent... Ils croisent
leurs doigts dans leur bureau
en se disant : Hum! On va
s'assurer qu'il y ait rien
qui se passe sur la route.
- 81-15, êtes-vous à l'écoute?
- Ici aussi, une partie
de la pression repos sur
les épaules des ambulanciers
qui craignent l'hiver.
- Partout, en Abitibi,
les chemins, ce n'est pas...
ce n'est pas les plus beaux
du Québec.
- On n'a pas vraiment de belles
conditions l'hiver. Souvent,
ça prend beaucoup plus de temps,
l'hiver, étant donné que
les routes sont moins bien
déneigées ou elles sont super
glissantes fait qu'on doit
faire super attention.
- On traverse une crise
sans lendemain.
- À court terme, le syndicat
des infirmières ne voit pas
de jours meilleurs se profiler à
l'horizon, même si le programme
de recrutement d'urgence du
gouvernement est plus généreux
ici qu'ailleurs au Québec.
JEAN SÉBASTIEN BLAIS,
président, FIQ-SISSAT
- Une main-d'oeuvre indépendante
qui vient des Laurentides,
de Montréal, qui vient ici
pour travailler, est-ce que
vous pensez qu'elle va vraiment
s'acheter une maison,
déménager et venir s'installer
en Abitibi-Témiscamingue
pour 3000 dollars?
- Bonne visite!
- De retour à Senneterre,
la visite du ministre n'a rien
changé. L'urgence est maintenant
fermée, même si la population
a joué la grande séduction.
- Je vous ai fait des beignes,
ce matin. C'est des beignes
atikamekw.
- Oh! des beignes atikamekw!
Eh boy! Je vais rentrer
le bedon un petit peu!
Merci beaucoup. Lâchez pas,
on va trouver des solutions.
- Une promesse difficile
à croire, tant ici
qu'à Ville-Marie.
JEAN-MAURICE MATTE,
maire de Senneterre
- Une fermeture 16 heures
par jour, c'est une fermeture
des lits d'hospitalisation,
et là, c'est plein d'autres
services qui sont touchés.
la responsable diabète
évidemment on mettra pas
quelqu'un à la radiologie.
On voit, dans cette fermeture-là
annoncée, une cascade
d'autres fermetures.
- T'sais, on l'aime notre Témis
et on est bien ici,
mais ce serait le fun
d'avoir aussi les services.
Oui, on est moins de population,
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on vaut
moins cher que les autres.
T'sais, des vies, c'est
des vies! Ça a la même...
ça vaut la même chose que ce
soit e